who doesn't like Godzilla he's big he
destroys things he has laser breath
pretty cool right well we are about to
get a game based on our beloved kaiju
fed Zilla the game is coming later this
year for PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 4
now the game looks a little weird on
first glance it looks like lag badilla
and the other characters move very
slowly and when they fall down and when
buildings crumble they're sort of this
stop motion effect according to the
developers that's intentional the
developer called this a click click boom
effect that's supposed to make it look
like the old Godzilla films and TV shows
of your I'm not a big fan of this it
slows down the action and kind of
doesn't look too good something that is
cool about this game however is you get
to play as any number of monsters from
Godzilla's past king dorohedoro three
different versions of Mechagodzilla
including super mecha godzilla and if
you're playing on the playstation 4
version you get SpaceGodzilla which is
arguably the coolest-looking of the
Godzilla's while the idea of playing as
Godzilla in destroying a city is pretty
neat I'm not really sure about the
aesthetics of the game or how it handles
it is a little choppy we'll see when it
comes out in July for more coverage of
Godzilla the game tune in to gamespot
com
you